هل هو واقع الحال ام ضرب من خيال لا يتفق
ولا يتفق مع ذات الاردنيين ولا ما حياتهم
وربما الفاظهم ومفرداتهم من هنا بدات نقطه
الخلاف حول في الملحره
والفقر الذي يعيش المواطن الاردني احداثه
الفيلم تدور في احدى حارات الاردن وتسلط
الضوء على تفاصيل حياه اهلها كجزء من
المجتمع يعاني الكثير طرح جاء من الواقع
لكن المستعجنه كان الفاظا لم تتقبلها
مسامع المشاهدين من خلال الدراما الاردنيه
حتى لو كان في من مجتمعنا هيك فئه المفروض
يحاربوها ما يعرضوها او يخلوها شيء طبيعي
يعني انه بحجه والله انه في من مجتمعنا
ناس بتحكي بهذه الالفاظ لا من عاداتنا ولا
من شيمنا ولا من اللي علموني جدودنا ولا
شيء من كل هذا العقيق يعني هسه لو جدي
وجدك عايشين اللي بيحضروا هيك اشياء يمكن
يذبحونها بصراحه
ما في هذه يعني في المواقع بتصور ما في
شيء
الجدل الى قبه البرلمان حيث انقسمت
المطالبات ما بين سحب الفيلم وايقاف عرضه
وصولا الى سحب الجنسيه من الفنان منذر
رياحنا لتبريره بان الفيلم رئه تعكس واقعا
حقيقيا اضافه لمطالبتهم برفع دعوه قضائيه
ضده لاساءته للهويه الاردنيه